[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to behind the screens the
weekly movies talk show where we deep
dive into a topic we love with a new
guest each week and this week I'm so
excited because I have the flashes
Keaton Lonsdale hi how are you I'm good
how are you good
you and I go sort of way back way back
way way back
so we first met in March 2015 mm-hmm and
I want to show you a snippet of this
interview because we are just a little
young so different look at us I don't
even know how to hold a microphone back
then cuz you were one of my first
on-camera interviews ever you thing yeah
and this was I think this was one of my
first that I was doing one of the first
yeah making milestones together so let's
take a look at it what is your favorite
thing to do while you're not working
play video games yeah yeah what's your
favorite wow I saw the trailer for that
no my friend has got that but I've been
like I'm like a massive Final Fantasy do
you know Final Fantasy that's that's my
everything yes number seven is the best
one so I play that a lot I'm so awkward
I love that though that's cute we bonded
over our little love of video games
which is great because that's the topic
we're gonna get into today is the best
and worst video game adaptations for
movies and we can agree that a lot of
them are not so great but before that
let's do a little catch-up with Cannon
here the flash is right around the
corner new season coming in October we
left off Barry Allen is I don't know
where well yes we're yes so where are we
picking things up with Wally
so in general with six months you know
ahead from Barry's disappearance into
the Speed Force and so Wally and the
whole team have sort of had to step up
together obviously well is the only
flash at this point so he's still kid
flash but he's you know had to take on a
lot of responsibilities iris is also
like sort of Manning the team is that
the right word yeah yeah yeah well many
missing Manning the team yeah and
killing it and yeah everyone's having to
sort of figure out how we work together
without
you know driving for us so it makes for
some interesting mysterious like he's
very conscious of this situation in
regards to iris and how this all affects
her so I think he's put his feelings
sort of towards the back and he's trying
to be as positive as possible throughout
this whole ordeal
well you are a jack of all trades an
actor a dancer a singer and we heard you
on the track light on me which is a
great just kind of some summer anthem
but what can we expect from you possibly
solo in the next week's months yeah
coming up so I am releasing like I'm
making an album I've been writing an
album for finally so cool I'm like yeah
it's a go and so the first single off of
that is going to be released like really
soon like how soon I'll be making an
announcement very soon because like if
something messes up then like then I'll
have to like retract it and like change
it that's the point disappoint people
understand I've done that before so I
feel like it's a long time coming I feel
like we've been talking about this for a
while so what is I mean what can you
tell me about the tone and the vibe of
the album yeah so it's a you know I've
changed a lot as a person and so
therefore my music has changed a lot
when I was releasing stuff a couple
years back it was a lot more like dark
and quiet like sensitive material and I
think cuz that's where I was at like
that's what I was talking about but now
I've sort of just like I'm very happy
and I'm trying to celebrate I want to
celebrate the things that make like our
generation awesome right and the things
about life that are awesome and let
people know that like we can have a good
time I want to ask you and we don't have
to dive to too personal but you did make
this post that got a lot of eyes on it
about loving everybody what has that fan
reception bin from people reaching out
to you and saying things like oh I'm so
glad he did this because this helped me
in some way
yeah it's been crazy you know people
contact me everyday and a lot of it's
like people saying that you know their
whole lives have changed and they've
built up so much confidence or even if
they're still struggling you know in
terms of like sexuality they feel so
inspired and they feel better about
themselves even in countries that don't
accept them they have more strength and
I was like that's really cool
yeah and so I think you know how I see
it is like we've seen so much in terms
of like people are oppressing themselves
we've seen like all the pain you know so
much loss that comes with that and so
much like yeah of the negative sides to
it and so I guess what I really realized
I can give and show people is like all
the joy that comes out of being yourself
right you know not the loss but the
gains so and I hope that people see that
and it can change their minds that's
great for people all over the world -
yeah that's the beauty of social media
right like it can be this dangerous
thing but it can also be one of the most
brilliant things as well see I love
social media I think it's done so many
great things for for for a lot of people
but for me - yeah you have to like you
have to figure out what it what does it
mean to you and once you once you accept
it for what it is you can you control
what you put out and you control what
people can write whatever they write to
you and they can do whatever but you get
to control how you feel about it right
or if you take it in or like if you want
comments if you post a photo or not like
you it is up to you and like the more
that people view it as a positive thing
and use it as a positive platform the
more that's what it becomes right
so we we have that power well let's dive
into the topic of the week the best and
worst video game adaptations there are
some okay ones and there are some bad
ones and I don't even know if there is a
great one but what is your favorite
video game movie of all time it would
have to be Pokemon like the first movie
oh my gosh that's what I put yeah okay
cool because I think that's a clear
winner I remember like when I didn't get
to see it in the movies when people were
giving out like them you cards like the
special cards yeah everyone in my school
got one like all the kids and so I
thought I was
crying about that but the movie itself
was so amazing did you have did you have
like a binder of Pokemon cards I did me
too
there was a kid named Kevin that stole
my holographic ride shoe and I and then
I found it in his binder and I knew it
was mine hmm
and he lied about it that that sucks and
I never got it back yeah the worst thing
that I ever did like one of the things I
always regret not regret but I'm just
like that was shady was when I was a kid
there was just like next-door neighbor
oh I did this too well I basically like
I didn't really like him that much but
he had at least cool Pokemon cards so I
was like I only played with him for his
pokemon cards to like try and win them
over and that was like that was a low
move but I was like I don't know how old
it was like nine I had a neighbor that
that did something like this to me like
she would play with me and then she
would take my cards and I remember I'd
go home and I'd be like oh like Julie -
I traded my Charizard for this like seal
card isn't it cute my mom would be like
we have to go down the street and get
your Charizard yeah are we getting it
back yes you've got so little yeah what
would you say is one that you were the
most disappointed in like you were
looking forward to it then it came out
you were like oh no it was I'm sorry it
was the Spirits Within okay
yeah I was pretty disappointed because
is that still your favorite game Final
Fantasy seven nuts set like now it's
it's I can't really choose I would say
actually 10 is my favorite oh I know
it's very commercial and that's like you
know everyone's like yeah but it is I've
that's the one I have replayed the most
because I'm just really into the story
and the characters and I don't know but
yeah I found like when the spirit Sweden
came out I was so excited I was also so
young so I just couldn't understand why
it didn't have a lot of the elements
like from the games that I loved so much
right and I also because I was so young
I couldn't tell if they were real enough
I hope the graphics right through me I
was like there's something wrong with
these people
they don't look like a little office
something off and I didn't realize it
was yeah it's the effects I think I
thought when I was younger that Tomb
Raider with Angelina Jolie was like the
best movie yeah and then I grew up and I
realized that it wasn't that great okay
I'll have to rewatch it
that's always disappointing this
happened to me with Space Jam recently
yeah so I don't recommend going back and
watching it because you go back and
watching you're like oh my gosh this
movie isn't that good do it do you think
it's just because times have changed and
so maybe like some of the jokes that
you're just not like quiet maybe like
there's not a lot keeping my attention
video to Space Jam yeah I think I was
just like oh Michael Jordan and Bugs
Bunny are finally on screen together
they finally very connected you finally
teamed up what about a video game movie
that you would want to see or maybe see
readin right I do want to see like I've
always imagined Final Fantasy 10 as a
film like a live-action film because I
just think I love Spira and the whole
world I think it's just so beautiful it
would be really cool to see it come to
life but also I don't know if I'm also
obsessed with Kingdom Hearts so I think
like yeah seeing that come to life would
just I think I would die do you think
that would work I don't know I think it
would take them 50 years to do it and
then if that was the case I would have
faith that they would do it right I
think that's the issue I have it's like
because I feel like I'm I work a lot and
I do music a lot usually the only games
I invest my time and my heart into his
final fantasy or Kingdom Hearts see
that's what I've been Crash Bandicoot oh
my gosh have you been playing the insane
trilogy me too because I don't have time
to dive into a whole new game where I'm
like invested for 150 hours I lose
myself yeah so now I've just been
playing levels of Crash Bandicoot yes
yeah and it takes me your age yeah
it takes me like a good day like oh just
one whole session to finish one level
now of Crash Bandicoot because I get so
frustrated like I keep dying so and the
more you die the quicker you try and get
it done I am you die again 100% sure
that the new and saint reality is 30
times harder it is right it is it's
harder it's not the same it's so hard it
is it's a real struggle and it's like
you definitely have to try and keep like
level-headed it's like challenging your
mind I do like a live stream where I was
doing the bonus look one of the bonus
levels and trying to get through it and
I lost my damn
really yeah yeah my issue is that I
don't know where all these boxes are
these special boxes oh no and I get to
the end it's like you've missed 23 boxes
and then it just keeps hitting me with
all these boxes that I missed yep
I find that really cruel because these
are like the first you know 10 levels or
so this should be the easiest thing and
you spend so much time you're like you
know what I'm gonna get all of them yeah
when you get to the end of the level and
you're like you missed three thousand
boxes boxes oh I went to every bonus
level I sent like 38 lives on thousand
boxes yeah I don't understand it
thank you so much for coming in talking
about this I know this is like kind of a
thing we connected on a couple of years
ago and I do I don't know if like a lot
of people know that you're super into
playing video games yeah and you know I
mean I'm quite disappointed in myself
like I've got a it's something that I
want to keep up and make sure like yeah
but you're not like a video game
journalist where it's like it's true
super sacrilege that you haven't played
a game it yeah it's a lot of time yeah
and I don't know if anybody knows but he
acts and dances and sings and does all
kinds of stuff oh you're so busy though
it's like it's like it's such an escape
it's it's a good escape I think yeah
sometimes like especially when I'm
playing Final Fantasy I'm like I do it
for days and then I go what have I done
like I literally do not want to go to
work at that point Oh No
and that's my job like at that point
I'll get fired so it's so sometimes it's
a thing where I'm like I stay away from
it on purpose because I did it's so
enjoyable I'm like I should go to a
shoot that I was assigned to yeah not
I'm late and I'm late I'm trying to find
three thousand boxes yeah but don't
exist but that's the beauty of it too
you do feel like you're being
transformed into a whole other world